c'est des propos signifiant mais qui
n'ont pas été signifiée ce n'est pas ce
qu'a dit le président de la république à
athènes les français sont feignants
enfin non mais vous vous voulez venir
ceux qui l'ont que celles qui l'ont
précédée ce qui n'était pas plus aimable
dans un débat républicain dont je crois
que c'est des propos volet on voit bien
que eux ils parlent me signifiant d'un
but
oui ces signifiants parce que le temps a
dit que l'univers culturel du président
de la république univers culturel du
président de la république c'est un
grand classique de la droite tout ce
qu'il dit en ce moment je n'ai entendu
bas à droite à savoir que les français
sont feignants qui sont rétifs aux
réformes qui foutent le bordel
voilà c'est tu sais c'est sa manière
d'appréhender les relations sociales
mais là il nomme les choses c'est encore
la défense de l'elysée à elie
effectivement il y à des jobs il faut
les prendre et cesser vérification faite
c'est le cas dans cette fonderies
d'ussel où il se trouve il ya des jobs à
prendre et des formations qui vont avec
il nomme les choses non une norme pas
les choses il dit qu une manifestation
c'est le bordel dans une
manifestation c'est des gens qui sont
dans la difficulté qu'ils peuvent avoir
un débouché et qui peuvent prendre des
emplois qui leur seront nécessaires pour
vivre mais il ya une angoisse
il faut la comprendre il faut la
recevoir on peut pas être dans le
surplomb faire la leçon en disant moi je
sais vous ne savez pas vous êtes des
petites gens moi je suis quelqu'un qui
va vous guider ça ce n'est pas juste du
point de vue de ce que doit être un
placard alors que les cas le présent
débat public il assume la teneur de son
propos même s'il regrette l'emploi d'un
mot familier bordel home il assume
il assume ses propos mais ça s'appelle
un déplacement ça ce qu'ils n'assument
pas bordel donc qu'est ce qu'il fait il
parle plus du bordel c'est à dire d'une
manifestation
mais il déplace le propos sur le fait
qu' il y à bien des emplois et qu'il
pourrait être
pourvu pourvu que maintenant des gens
mais c'est pas ça le sujet il fait comme
si on était idiot c'est pas ça le sujet
c'est que il pense que des gens qui
manifestent foutent le bordel
ce ne sont pas ses comptes devraient pas
manifester on devrait dire amen balle et
je crois qu'ils se trompent
la société française elle est plus
complexe que ça en tous les cas plus
rétives à la parole présidentielle